mathieu bons centres accueilleront sur
tout le monde donc mathieu on se
retrouve enfin pour commenter un
événement où on ne joue pas et où on est
pas on n'a pas partie prenante on n'est
pas partie prenante quoi presque un
plaisir de passes tressées pour en
regardant les parties démentent et ou de
cannes comme prochaines cibles
ouais ça ça nous fait ça nous fait un
peu de changement et attend alors une
seconde je veux juste voir que la
technique soit bien ouais ça doit être
ça doit être partie et mais on ya
convient quand même tout d'un mathieu
excuse moi j'ai un peu peur mais je dis
d'ailleurs j'allais te demander comment
tu comptes est organisé pour les rondes
moi je suis pour suivre un ou deux mecs
et après on tournera on verra qui est en
forme on en fera peut-être un moment
c'est exact je pensais exactement la
même chose et en cochon et lauda parce
que bon le keynote police haider et
n'est pas peut-être quelqu'un je kiffe
ans et en une
il n'a pas joué les deux derniers jours
il me semble n'en n'est pas aussi 6 il a
joué je n'ai pas vu du tout alors il a
dû très bien loin au total 12 c à passer
comme en tête en bas le premier tournoi
ça s'est pas trop mal passé je crois que
j'ai fait finalement 14 ennemis 14 et
demi ce qui devrait et le deuxième jour
je te cache pas que j'étais un peu dans
le dur parce que c'est pas bien passé au
début et puis après j'avais un peu je
n'avais plus la rage tu vois pas ce que
je faisais ces jeux suivants pour les
5-6 l'année ronde les deux jours breni
times d'ailleurs j'ai bien poids cfi
rhodiole premier jour j'ai dit [ __ ] il
est monstrueux il a fait 4 et fait suite
aux femmes il a quand même gagné
la dengue et nièces et hier résultats de
fouet
pour pondre ça je crois il s'appelle je
les ai déjà vus ok il avait déjà 2009
sur le site hein c'est pas un inconnu
mais ouais il ya des ponts mais bon pas
à ce point là j je pensais pas tu vois
moi non je pense que lui non plus mais
pas j'espère mais ok après on voit qu'il
était spécialiste par exemple tang
arrive et on lui donne quoi mais je te
rappelle que moi je les jouais au
deuxième et chic et ouais j'ai fait deux
fois plus de points de fil c'était du 10
minutes mais en une minute il découvre
enfin ces mecs les spécialistes c'est
une savate intéressant lorsqu'il ya
plusieurs types de joueurs il ya les
spécialistes et les mecs temps juste bon
échec un peu les deux écoutons là on a
la partie de police fighter contrat
meurt donc là j'ai envie de te dire ça
sans rsa de deux jours qui on est oui
amr en a d'autres à chiquer prendre les
5 ce que je voulais d'échiquier excusé
pour le pour la première partie comme je
comprends que mes oreilles la ouvriers
hadji cissé en fin mai mais la deux
places pour la torse et les choses ok
donc du coup je sais pas si toi tu que
tu commences souvent du bellay sont à
chen nan le but là tu commentes rarement
est alors du coup y'a du vocabulaire
télé jambon avant 1
alors qu'est-ce que flag et blaguer
alors sans gloire - chatons mais on va
en voir en gros il n'ya pas d'art ajoute
tant séduit une minute k o et donc du
coup quand y quand on est complètement
foutu et qu'ils noueraient à trois
secondes
bayrou joue à fond jusqu'à jusqu'à que
le en espérant que l'agresseur est
palpable matin est ok il ya aussi le
prévenu est hyper important explique m
à bien jouer ça fout des trois prix
scaër 3 way pour meetic il pouvait
peut-être le flashy il pouvait peut-être
c'était même aux voiliers lesquels moins
bien et donc du coup il ya le pré mussig
à la portant à vous expliquer ce qu'ils
connaissent pas trop ces tempêtes on
peut jouer un coup avant que ce soit aux
jo en espérant que ça soit pas un
mauvais coup parce que tu sais pas ce
que ton adversaire la joie mais en gros
c'est pour jouer le court instantanément
quasiment instantanément c'est un double
avantage c'est qu'en plus tu gagne du
temps et en fait perdre à l'adversaire
parce que lui du coup il n'a pas eu le
temps de faire son prêt move et donc tu
accélères mais la police fighter il va
perdre un show dit tout de suite après
il faut il en plus il est moins bien
longtemps se voyait dès 2007 dont classe
après mousse de partout mais bon ça
suffit pas donc dans ces cas-là entier
qu'elle est noire il a pas besoin de
chercher à gagner mais juste à jouer des
coups sans casque blanche prévue mode
époux de dame mais ça va gagner tout ça
d'ailleurs hier j'ai vu un prêt mousse
café de pâte de de jules joffrin notre
frenchie café 7e bien déjà ralentir
qu'un très bon et ça enchaîne tout de
suite rendu compte alors c'est un match
sans double à les océans double
aller-retour donc à partie ces quatre
partis alors attends je vais essayer de
régler juste le jeu voilà que j'ai un
petit bug pour le deuxième écran je
comprends pas trop pourquoi parce que la
connexion elle est censée pas avoir de
problème j'ai la fille chez moi mais
juste sur la petite mise en place le
petit début mathieu way et ça devrait
revenir donc à nous cacher l'écran juste
une seconde et je sais pas pourquoi ça
marche et quand j'ai fait les tests mail
a fortiori ça fonctionne pas et je sais
pas pourquoi mais alors du tout du goût
ce temps toute ronde avec quatre pompes
par personne chaque match exact exact du
joueur qui joue à dix joueurs c'est beau
ça va faire beaucoup de parties basses
avec 40 secondes à mais du coup ça
enchaîne plus vite que quand il ya un
tournoi se soit laissé en chaîne s'est
enchaîne ça enchaîne on va on va
sûrement retrouver le classement là en
bas et je sais pas pourquoi
as été obligé de te connecter c'est pour
ça c'est pour ça que pour leur mettre le
pour mettre le classement jean tu vois
en bas je viens de me connecter comme ça
oui voilà prison comme moi john bowman
pas donc police guinéenne depuis ce
matin
de m'attendre d'homme d'état matin et
d'un f 3,3 matin c'est 2-2 trop j'espère
que ça va marcher mais bon voilà c'est
le début qu'est ce qu'on fait on rassure
c'est un mini match
ouais je pense un non moins mauvaise que
hammer il distribue tout le temps tu as
tu le joues donc les gens connaissent et
ils nous la colère et avait donc perdu
d'ailleurs ils sont fait défaut démonter
un ils étaient menés 8 4 à voir le avant
le dernier match et ils ont ignoré
vraiment aucune chance à ma meilleure il
est impressionnant dans cette rude comme
ça bon là mais là ils ont changé leur
féminine
ils ont mis clés à quoi m aux derniers
bas salaires mieux la grèce a par contre
nous a fais jamais de point
ouais on les avait battus à l'ailé
stockholm et iraniens cette année on
s'était dit allons y avait gagné
d'ailleurs la dernière rencontre
stockholm dans le match dans le match
contre stockholm tu seras pas de passer
duda qui a battu meilleur ami son nom du
chien moi je parlais de la battle quand
il avait joué le truc horrible as tu
veux dire la battle pris le matin et
donc les blancs sont un peu mieux mais
le hockey typique du bullet c'est pas si
grave ça pour le coup j'ai cette ville
le cavalier pour un jouet livecad vous
seriez peut développer il ya sept mois
ouais mais il ya huit secondes d'écart
donc avantage non un plus takam un peu
après je ne sais même pas sûr qu
objectivement tu sois vraiment
maintenant j'attends quand même un pion
de plus et jetez 5000 inscrits dans le
si ce type au tour des scrutins qui tout
réussit souk et de trois voyez la
laiterie qui a pris la 6 paul inquiètent
donc là ça drague unis profitent pas
donné la tôt
bien gérer le temps 15 contre 22,3 j'ai
deux tours f3 bois c'est l'échangé s'il
attaque hsf madame swing pour hachette
rectorat ce qui est 5ème et tutoie tour
3 twh 5
c'est bizarre de pas clos et menacer el
kasri et une pièce qui sait pas si
facile que ça gagne et non un tourin
chaque agent avait fait un tour des 3 un
clouage la rsa jeu il est plus rapide un
néant
ouais ça joue vite un bon ok on comprend
comment hockey d'antan mais maintenant
il faut pas dit on moi je prétends prend
1,6 angers 4 on est trop long et trop
long pour être quatre faux qui prime le
comprend 27 et qui est l'ajout de temps
quand il ya tellement il ya tellement de
coups qui arrivent en même temps que ça
mais c'est le foot pages entreprises at
il attendu voire voix des briques de
couet mairie il est tombé 1 minul eh
ouais voyez les liens il faut absolument
prendre le dernier pion dans ces cas là
parce que si tu tombes
ça fait que nul ouais ouais c'est hyper
important de prendre que l'adversaire
est passé de matériel pour mater
je sais quand cette cadence en son fond
plat d'ouverture mais comme il ya une
anecdote marrante son stoppeur turna
quand il a vu les gones qu'elle avait
que 3 s'est inventée par un chroniqueur
aux candidats une autre gueule font à
londres et ce qui est marrant c'est que
j'avais parlé avec havre qui travaillait
comme seconde en de cramer qui dit on a
bossé pendant un mois on a trouvé
quasiment aucune idée sur la route fait
elle peut être pas après le match il ya
ce tournoi et il place cette nouvelle
idée sur l'éventuelle cm qui continue à
bosser non stop ils trouvent des idées
là aux places en main et après ça a été
deux à la mode par le pôle mov'eo en
france le réseau romain la lentille
grünfeld a récolté le troquet demain et
ce qui est critique en théorie c'est la
présence et quatre mandats dans la
partie d'appréhender 5 mai ce qui donne
au moment de payer ce bug lors du plus
fort et tu peux tu préférais koala à
voir
car de fous où le cavalier parce que
c'est du bullet je suis pas spécialiste
du monde et un ok mais là je prends
juste c'est complètement les gamins 5e
en bullet sajoo 1 6 seconde avance pour
duda bas salaires bon avec les blanches
pour une jeune fille au prince 5 b 4
pouces et 1 c'est quand même bien bien
bête mais c'est à qui joue pour les 15 à
4 x 6 essais dangereuse qui de temps en
temps il joue pour le guerrier pas
fourni les cassures fois ci ce qui
protégeait le connaissez sûrement oublié
par les deux il n'y avait pas deux du
coup faute reculant posée mais bonne
chance reprend un pion prend j'aurais
pris du roi pour mais bon ok a bien joué
et chaque pompier que le roi passe mais
on se souvient final les réceptions
majoré mon père il faut être non parce
que tu peux jouer un rôle de leader en
moyenne 5
c'est incroyable ce qu'il a fait non
ouais c'est bien joué 26 pour éviter
tout geste est touché et le temps est
pas sûr qu il est en drive a gagné 6,6
la gagne avec eux il laisse deux dames
âgées une seconde - freine friendly cnl
et noir et blanc ouais bah ils auraient
pu être malin et enfin bon on peut pas
faire de ne pas faire d'un vrai mais bon
soyons sûrs que la bernard prend b2 et
apple ne prêtez pas de pré move qui
aurait laissé la pollution pour s
enquérir on regarde les résultats
ouais alors attends on a on a les scores
ça et ses revenus nepomniachi un battant
et dans l'est des scores ils sont ils
sont ils sont moyennement à jour
honnêtement par exemple juminer la
première en france
ouais ouais ouais les scores les scores
c'est un peu galère quoique yammer avec
un il a deux souhaits auxquels sont ils
sont
il y avait un sens de il a perdu la
deuxième il ya que leur en l1 a salué l'
ya 2 robotnik l'emmenant ils ont
deux en fait il ya trois points ok mais
pour gagner 3-1 qu'on ne marque de skis
un 4-0 ou là il a mis 4 0 acquis à en
scène où il met à jour en forme mesure
donc on sait pas trop contre qui se
soldent way meilleur hand c'est noël à
saint c'est un peu c'est un peu
difficile de savoir les corps au
caractère il ya le pingouin qui a trois
et demi il ya des pots qui a quatre là
il a fait zéro défaut pour sa voix
rauque est donc tombée il a battu salem
c'est le seul 15h30 mais juste la
general ode à amherst et maintenant et
en scène un 10-0 aussi ouais donc
nepomniachi au fait de cfa battus
meilleur et en scène
ouais et pornic tu te rappelles de
l'ubpa pente mais j aurais tu l'avais
joué en pro che smic est sorti une
nouveauté non et que tu l'avais battu
d'ailleurs belge avait gagné 1 mais un
parti au deuxième derrière j'ai fait
deuxième dans la quarantaine
mais bon c'est une victoire 2e dan par
contre là où je galère un peu c'est
qu'en fait je peux suivre tous les
joueurs facilement sauf police fighter
ou gecko observé game mais ok donc et on
regarde police fighter contre narrow à
ça j'ai déjà ok ok ok en apprendre bien
avant dépôt parce que c'est
impressionnant quand même 4 4 0
on commence et je comprends pas pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai des trucs du score qui bug
en fait moi et c'est peut-être eu un non
non non je pense que j'ai passé quand je
lance une partie sur pias comme j'arrive
plus à voir j'arrive faire le truc de
twitch pour pourra voir les scores qui
sont à jour ok mais du coup je vois que
la pause - quand tu fais ce n'est pas
moi non plus mais je sais pas trop
pourquoi ça marche en fait tant qu à
peine parti en cours sur casse comme le
truc marx et vol et rue du coup ce
serait bonne ligue avait gagné une super
partie prix de beauté et là les mecs ils
sont là seulement c'est juste moi
j'arrive pas à jouer sans réfléchir
immense en monstre donc la police
facteurs vague n'est pas s'il a deux à
un bon je vais quand même faire une
demande
je vais juste écrire pour dire que j'ai
un bug des cas parce que tu peux changer
de parti au padduc ou touchantes
traitant la prochaine du coup bah en
fait marrer ce pont serait sûr surtout
pas qu'on va pas changer de partout
alors ok donc vous voyez pas regarder ce
qu'il a plus de points c'est un mais
c'est un jeune en fait américain et qui
joue pas mal hein j'ai pas de contrer
une fois encore il ya 200 m et 14
blessés sur internet riches fighters et
en tant que c'est un peu nouveau qui
soit 120 heures après les jeunes il a
tout pour réussir santana contre apple
en pièce quand il a eu beau tout cas
utile et youtube c'est un peu pour ça
qu'on a répété d'ailleurs c'était
impressionnant
mais mes nordisk a plus de mots clés sur
le site par exemple ce qui est pour moi
une disant facebook pour moi n'y a pas
aimé non bouddha c'est en fait c'est
juste la classe au-dessus bondoukou
après en bullet s'avère absolument et
bien moi qui ai match retour et pour moi
il ya 1 0 dans une autre affaire
longuet dans une descente hoorens pour
les gens ne s'intéressent pour regarder
le livre de brûlures sur le cadre des 6
vite que tu remets aux caisses et
imaginatif
après honnêtement le livre est bien
parmi ces quatre des six les gens en
partie non à la ja ces quatre îles et
oublier l'atelier une pièce non il a des
pions il a les compensations monsanto en
bullet avec le curage mais bon ce
quelqu'un ming en gros le b site c4 b6
très bons coups keller 3b si totalement
jeu parce que maintenant 1 96 m lequel
ces trois des quatre b 6 des cas tu
penses que ça égalise pas mais ça reste
jamais plus je pense qu'on a vu que
christian dumont le jeu une fois je
pense pas que j'ai pu mais mais bon là
ça va faire un partout il est malin
mentoring tonnes qui sont simplement
faux c'est vite parti pis d'un très bon
comme une lettre va jouer 1,6 maintenant
montré beaucoup trop court d'ailleurs à
4 à 5 de la tourache trois peut-être un
pour trouver des contre-feux mais bon
français qui manque une torrent mais bon
buvette faut faire attention mais ira
seul mais bon les noirs sont mieux
autant mieux dans la position
ok il ya aussi un truc qu'on n'utilise
pas forcément leur échec mais en bullet
il est important le rush
quand tu commences à mettre à enchaîner
les victoires attends à il a rendu l'âme
il a vendu à des fins il a ravi a perdu
la tour il a il a gaffé
il a sept enfants achètent dames et chez
kantar média les coûts la dame après les
changes la dame défend des prix
ok willy aux quelques billets seront
regroupées la semaine sur une case noire
et après le roi va coucher alors il va 4
ce qui fait ses gammes en d5 l'esprit
donc l anglais il peut prix mauvais pas
mal de moudre aux 7,3 kg de qe3 après os
qui va qui est enfin reparti avec le roi
dracula mais le camion de b4 où le roi
et dans le car les prisons roi de deux
mails envoyés dans le carré dans quatre
secondes il a gagné dans ma main clés
blanc ce qu'elle a en plus il peut
imprimer
minipoussins change en fait quand on
prie mousse il en apparaît faire un coup
illégal
du coup ça ralentit grave les primo en
typique quand les gens ont pu l'être il
met dame automatique un obligatoire
auquel il a fait deux dames seront peut
être embêtant c'est pas je sais pas
pourquoi on se reçoit des séries de
coups mais il a fait patte il a fait
patte avec trois dames mais ne verrait
pas tech3 damon mais l'amérique tapas à
3,9 oui on a des skis qu'elle agit la
[Musique]
bonne question je sais pas trop je pense
qu'ils ont le même agent narrow dit ce
qui est police fighter ouais je pense à
peu près way les trois dames vous faire
passer le prend pour un con on peut et
on doit bien ça fait pas normalement on
fait 2 et tu fais un math
quels liens de l'escalier ouais donc là
je préfère les blancs les noirs elles
ont bloqué la pause monde se prendre une
grosse attaque quelle 3 kg quatre fermes
atteignant jusqu'à trois ans ou plus y
en a qui disent mais ça m'étonne de bah
ouais parce que c'est vrai qu'il est
vraiment jeune mais qu'il a sacrifié
donc d'un match ici les ces petits bouts
château rue de foix et fuite qui piquent
pour chasser un peu optimiste et du cac
et cinq bien des dents les enfants a
levé un veto à 2 knight audi une menace
rien ma politique batteur tu allais
gagner salanon ouais mais bon celle
d'avant on pensait qu'il allait gagner
mais là déjà 100 kgs en forme et donc
peut-être qu'elle en quatre ans il
décide de faire prendre
il soutenait jusque là une menace prise
est d'un machisme et comment tu pars le
matin il faut prendre de la dame très
bien joué non mais je pense qu'il peut
la perdre un seul un d'un match la mâche
katsura trois prochains crise prises
dans ma fille bien joué avec tempo d'un
match que tu vas jean fauque défense
tourbez entourage croit tourcoing le 20
mai était leur voyage de 2 je veux
qu'elles dépensent donc il va le terrain
tour 5
ouais ok mais tu fais pions comprendra
cinq n'ont aucune idée je reviens
entourage trois temps et yahia pas
d'idée typique un ouais ok police
fighter qui a du mal hein parce que la
premier match il a fait
ouais il a fait il a fait 2-2 là c'est
la nuit en commentaire dans le chatt
ouais bah oui c'est vrai que c'est pas
que c'est con on sait juste en fait tu
fais la deuxième dame parce que tu prêt
mou de pousser pousser pousser et après
tu as juste à gagner tranquillement géré
avec deux dames qui fait mal et connecte
à nier qu'on appelle et c'est le truc
apprend à faire quand tu as deux ans
donc il le sait est là il n ya fait
flamber cinq jeunes enfants mailly avait
compensé le recueil ces trois plans b 4
x hd terrible derrière un pion des six
auxquelles les grandes et petites
j'avais pas fait récemment c'était ma
toc et les blancs sans gagnant est jeune
et elle 30 secondes en salle et de la
gagner donc il remplace on fouille ils
veulent échanger et pièce d'august ils
échangent passé contre se prendre ça
mais bon ça va encore où l'as aminé
touahri mairie cette offensive sur les
iphone 3g crise tout se délite
ouais enfin c'est beau c'est beau c'est
beau mais c'est pas si efficace que ça
au final non un méprendre c'est typique
il est au dessus mais il fait pas un bon
match
franchement je trouve qui galère galère
geek avec une caisse de plus et ça fait
deux fois qui nous fait le coup ok bah
c'est vrai est très très très bien joué
dans ce but puisque le mec entre mouz
direct f5 parce que le pense la presse
ici pensent plus à bouger ok bien joué
tu peux développer l'idée du voyage de
la capture des six mais le voit c'est
que la structure des blancs est figé au
centre du coup deux fois 2e étape dans
un mur parce qu'il ya eu 7 des six donc
du coup il a du mal à faire quelque
chose de ces pièces est d'ailleurs il a
réussi à ne sortir que l'entente après
ok donc on voit un peu le classement
ouais
oui on voit on voit un peu le classement
et le classement voit que c'est bortnik
7 points nepomniachi 6
mais il met à jour en différents thèmes
pas les fêtes des attentes hier j'ai
suivi ces partis il a terminé il s'est
pas qualifié à cause de la dernière
ronde
oui faire d'ailleurs contre sale el
arabi falcon une ironie demande-t-il
très propre pour du bullet big fish en
1995 fait dossier a donc un jeune grand
maître russe assez prometteur pas le
christ buzzer de la génération et en
plus tu lane un peu dans l'ombre à
retenir même et du coude en suisse en
train de regarder un peu le classement
et je vois que hammer il est bien quand
même avec 6 donc il échoue il faut
constituer un dépôt peut-être idiot qui
n'est pas là c'est la pause donc on sait
pas exactement par contre ce que je dois
dire c'est que meilleur et et en scène
ils ont zéro alors ça c'est quand même
dur à croire mais ils ont zéro sur huit
quoi c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
quand même non ouais ouais c'est ça la
cagoule est ce que c'est vraiment même
temps tu veux que je te dise ça donne
mais ça va être rigolo avoir le même
qu'à 0 108 équipes stream serait de fait
l'enfer je vais juste répondre pour le
bug donc là ça marche non en fait quand
il n'y a pas de partie sur pièce comme
un atout qui marche dès qu'il ya une
partie qui sont sur pièces comme j'ai
compris d'où venait le bug donc désolé
aux débutants et un peu de mal mais en
fait dès qu'il ya des partis qui sont
sur pièces comme ça fait bugger twitch
hockey sa partie je vais faire en fait
c'est entre les parties et je vais
récupérer classement autrement c'est
pour ça ça vous regarde pas cela
ça ne m'intéresse pas trop à mener en or
des dauphines ouais on va aller on va
aller on va aller chercher autre chose
non mois du dépôt on va aller chercher
du nippo
alors on invente nick ça m'intéresse pas
de hockey ça va être super la partie
mais je sais c'est des magouilles
maintenant lui parler mais qui essaie de
me ruiner en plus ne faut il joue contre
fait de cfa2 ok super match donc ils
connaissent très bien ils tant l'équipe
nationale en sang donc vous voulez ça
ressemble plus à des échecs exactement
ce que c'est ce que j'aime bien c'est
d'essayer de jouer plus ou moins
classiques bras plaisante me perds tu
rien surtout n'est pas parce que des
projets pas si vous connaissez un peu
ces partis maman partie l'ongle des fois
ça part en cacahuète
là tu mets un truc en d6 la tête mais
bon ça te tiens tu me tiens c'est
symbolique et pourrait faire mieux là
c'est facile
non qu'il faut pas en bullet faut
toujours même si je vous prends à
pourquoi faut toujours faire attention
quand même à la bcc les deux c'était
tacticien allait cesser de se planter
nebo au fait il a un peu le c'est pas ça
va être chaud qu'il s'agit il ya un peu
de de similitudes avec maxime ah bah ça
ne choque pas du tout après pas pour
tous il a un style plus crade mais icade
groenefeld nage dans quand il joue un
âge d'or finit toujours moins bien comme
maxime mais par contre une arnaque
toujours au maximum
il sent les positions dynamique c'est la
folie énorme d'aaland qui m'avait
raconté qu'il était un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde débute demain et c'est
ottaway donc la tour sete torje 6 les
blancs sont quasiment gagnant maintenant
waouh sera les deux pièces pour vous
fait deux pions fait des cas très bien
joué tout en contrôle
à hilla centre et découragent degrés il
a tenté d'acheter pour milla il s'est
pris 22 secondes conduite donc au big
fish je m'attendais pas le beau racing
voilà sur internet oui dès l'es2
ils ont même et loire je pense pas que
ce soit des gros habitués du nul j'ai
déjà vu n'ai pas joué mon général tendu
3 0 ok donc un dragon petite surprise
mais tu vois ce qui me ce qui étonne
c'est qu'on attendait enfin en tout cas
en russie attendait surtout attendre un
flot d'un an
il lui a placé ce qui piège
à montrer dans les écoles pour prendre
un cas métiers des noirs sont mieux
maintenant c'est pas si clair quand même
il ya du plomb dans l'ailé blonde que le
tacle un âge ils attaquent tous et la
partie d'après ces trois de théâtre mâle
est vraiment mieux je pense que oui
qu'est matériel montrent à quoi tu as
1 2 3 4 5 tu peux pas vous fait la
chaîne pascal hattu peu et à éprouver ce
sont le temps d'un coup il ya plutôt
rachat il a raté ça du coup il va
falloir tout une manière pour aller
chercher plus tard à menacer les
suppressions le mans - je reprends un
chef qui a voulu donner pour se donner
une idée a l'impression que ce n'est pas
il a du mal un japon qui cherchent des
tactiques et que feydeau secafi le musée
nan très très propre ces deux se dit
donc il était vraiment avancer la boum
pour transposer les finales de la marche
x 5
bienvenue donc très propre assez rapide
pas c'est pas du pingouin offre pas
moins c'est pas un mauvais cependant
c'est vraiment le pseudo du méridien
vous allez voir sur notre regarder des
parties de vue plus tard c'est il joue
super vite
c'est la folie pays et aussi la
dextérité aménagé s'il faut faire
attention bien joué elle à texter rites
et pour faire un f4 s'y attend lundi
pour un bref séjour à bien jouer il va
faire belle pour que tel qui n'a autant
cette offre qui allie les 4 b 4 sinon
bienvenus ablaye faye s'est gâté pousser
plus loin il va envoyer cas du sun bolt
sur la colonne un broyat 3.51 beaupré
moulin à tan alors huit ans autant quand
même simple peu chaud ouais moi par
contre c'est la partie c'est le master
class
finalement il n'y avait vraiment la
guinée va j'espère que bienvenu mais
c'est parce que c'est le défaut de hype
ousmane le pion ouais c'est un typique
il fallait il est fun c'est comme ça où
des gâteaux des quatre agrafes ou t4 id
2 arrive c'est bon ils arrivent attendre
n'y a pas d'acte enveloppe d'une aide à
lever 5 un prince
il a aussi d'apprendre 3 qui prend un
tour et maintenant tu fais d'ailleurs il
a permis de regarder des asexuels ok ya
eu pas tant il est tombé il ya eu pas
tes pattes mais c'est pas ça peut ça
peut qu un peu sur la fin je sais pas
pourquoi
peut-être que tu as trop de trucs
ouverts en même temps sur les caméras
les trucs mais honnêtement c'est pas la
première fois que je le fais normalement
non non non c'est pas à temps et nagui
big fish un spécialiste c'est un type il
est très souvent classé premier sur deux
chaises comme un piège savais pas mais
il a pas d'enfant il à 2009 donc il
n'est pas non plus fin que 2009 un an
pourquoi il ya égalité parce que quand
or fat
alors quand le mec à 0 autant et que mes
parents ont ils à 0 pièce c'est là qu'il
avait plus de moyens légaux de gagner la
partie a déclaré mieux et des fois pas
tant pas tu sais quand il ya le roi ne
peut plus bouger et personne ne garde
rien obligé mais par contre il n'ya pas
échec
regardez pas une ambiance ici se fait
dominer pour il a essayé par fait
d'amener un très bien j'avais défini la
dépôt il va être obligé d'échangés
d'état mais qu'est-ce deux mois et non
je suis dit big fish peut-être la
machine 1 0 abandon boom entre les
pauvres dépôts qui se fait dominer denis
en demi et c'est pas mal payé quoi c'est
pas mal tu es en nous disant de chaque
pornic se fait retourner par point mais
passons d'une boarding honnêtement je
suis aussi ouhlala big fish il sait il
s'est fourvoyé mais à regarder on c7 est
ce qu'il va se passer demain demain 5
qu'elle pourra quand même à tours s'est
associé au cabinet d'éric à six heures
d'efforts
takieddine s'est agacé à bitche 1,9 au
prince is no 3 s'est mépris aussi permis
à wil à l'alhambra g8 et l'avoir trouvé
en la gay pride et cagoulés ont fait là
c'est kaboul parce que normalement il a
le niveau pour trouver le français
lassé cagoule mais bon il est encore
bien il est regardé avril à 12 secondes
plus on m'a demandé quand est ce que je
suis venu grand maître il ya plus de dix
ans j'avais 22 ans entre 22 29 ans a
bien joué qu'elle paraisse un hack belle
rousse hyper fort parce qu'en plus il ya
eu un titre en baisse est donc les
blancs sont mieux des gameiro h six
hommes s'affairent - gagnants tutu prend
tôt tu prends à swiss tu rases tu restes
eurent as tu des sphères d'arrêt après
tu bouffes à chaque bourde est simple
c'est complètement gagnant je pensais
qu'il était de faire d'un point f2 pour
le roi j'ai 3 et 6 go en raid 5 et bien
il est bien payé mais pour devenir un
ennemi là il est bien payé c'est encore
un qui est super des frais qu'ils aiment
c'est juste un bug du côté twitch écoute
tu perds pas de fremm donc la connexion
ça va il ya eu un bug quelque part tout
à l'heure quand j'avais twitch ouvert
pour récupérer les scores mais la sale
impression de se stabiliser
ok ferme la partie il va avoir les
cordes
ouais alors les scores atteints on m'a
donné un lien pour les récupérer j'ai
dit que ça me gay quand on ouvrait sur
twitch donc je vais je pouvoir récupérer
les bus pour aller récupérer autrement a
pas besoin
j'ai pour aller récupérer votre vin nous
sommes ensemble sa galère un peu plein
de ton truc
oui et non ok je suis assez curieux de
voir qui en tête maintenant peut-être
plus qu'un espoir né peau fait dos en
tête alors attends je vais ouvrir et
j'en conviens de tête d'assister au
match le plus intense en je vais
récupérer sa non non en fait
en fait c'est quand il ya des partis qui
démarre
c'est quand elle est partie qui démarre
que je ne sais pas pourquoi ça donc là
on vient de faire trois rondes style il
en reste six exact à une bulle est
intense
donc les gars là je sais pas si vous
avez compris donc là c'est le dernier
jour de khalifa et à partir de demain
c'est la folie et des biens joueurs du
monde à part minus et tous les meilleurs
joueurs du monde sont là plus ceux qui
se sont qualifiés en gagnant détendant
monstrueux dans les tournois de lire
être là aujourd'hui si on le gagne c'est
un super haut niveau et donc donc demain
c'est la folie donc c'est quoi c'est
demain c'est des matches à élimination
directe exact serait donc ça va être
super intéressant à suivre
ça sera plus facile pour nous de suivre
les classements parce que c'est des
matchs en main c'est entre deux
personnes qui s'était passé mais là on a
réussi assez bon on a tout récupéré mon
arme en a on aura un peu raté le début
mais tu vois du coup maintenant aller
les classements évoqués dont on vient de
voir le match entre les deux premiers en
fait ouais je te propose se propose
qu'on suive peut-être
amr amr ouais bah c'est bon c'est quoi
le prochain match
les prochains matchs et je te cache pas
qu'il y ait une petite pause par contre
ce que je vois tout le monde en ligne
avec ça je vous parle on l'a suivi trois
matches c'est ça on est bien d'accord
donc attendre qu'ils aient lâché en fait
à meyer et en scène j'ai envie que les
gens ont fait 2 2 ils sont au fond à
roadies qui sale et duda mon avis ça va
se jouer entre
[Musique]
ok bortnik ça peut être intéressant de
suivre parce qu'ils sont à 8 500 prend
moi honnêtement ce que j'ai vu pour moi
le meilleur set feydeau c'est un bref et
de ses fils a été bon et duda il n'a pas
été terrible terrible non j'ai pas très
impressionnant après inquiet quand on se
rappelle dans les speechs s ils avaient
ils avaient bien je comprenais tout en
aura sept terrains spécialement non il
m'a pas tout elle m'a pas impressionné
enfin tu as hammer enfin moi je suis
curieux de voir rameurs face à ces mecs
là je suis curieux de voir à murray a eu
personnellement
ouais mais après c'est bon c'est un peu
le défaut que je fais à thiès points
comme c'est agréable beaucoup le site
mais je ne sais jamais clair les
appariements l'extrait il faudrait qu'il
sait comment protéger c'est de retrouver
les résultats c'est l'enfer bref c'est
l'enfer et c'est dommage qu'ils sont pas
loin de 20 leur confection et fantasmé
juste faire un classement un incident
plus clair ça mais c'était souvent très
bordélique un jeu je ne peux que quatre
policiers retrouvent mais moi j'ai ma
non mais tu voi apparente à duda qui a
remarqué on savait pas été il avait
encore une partie en cours donc en fait
il a 6 ennemis tu as eu lieu à redevance
à amr et les formules est en accord et
c'est vrai en plus c'est un amateur cas
qu'aucune qu'aucun sans gêne il est
content de battre dans laquelle il y en
a qui dit que may enfin lampédusa cause
des connexions ça c'est qu'on sait artes
qu'ils enfreindraient c'est terrible
magnus ne voulait pas jouer dans le mât
mieux c'est en léger 1
on fit plus ou moins masqué avec 13
points comme et donc ouais bah non il
est surtout sur 3 24 ouais après n'était
pas ses amis thiès un moment un peu de
partout après après magnus que je disais
même dans un tournoi comme ça il n' y
seraient favoris mais tu vas contre un
mec comme déjà contre firoud déjà il
avait un peu galéré en une mais un peu
galéré enfin vous rendez pas compte il
suffit rosehill à guînes et on a mis
hier afin aventure avec des monstres et
il lui a mis c'était du tout pour un cas
donc attendre il ya le classement encore
évoluer à venir en fait c'est portes
nique en tête mais as tu sais pourquoi
ne pas abandonner la troisième très
rapidement ah oui c'est pour ça
peut-être que william est l âge de 35
ouais bon mais ça a permis de faire de
voir un peu classement donc bortnik on
suppose qu'on suive portique du boult
aux bois dans le portique pouvez
regarder les gens
la partie continue ça fera plaisir après
c'était pas d'une minute un mois
honnêtement je n'aurais aucune chance et
je suis beaucoup trop longs ont déjà là
texte hérité avec la souris je n'en
parle même pas mais même voir la
tactique suis pas fait mal hein faut
être vraiment très qui pour être bon
mais celui qui m'étonne toujours c'est
quand même le pingouin dans le sens où
tu as tous les walis il est pas très
fine et vachement à chaque fois il est
25e paris les 26 non je crois que j'ai
25 20 c'est ça qui m'étonne c'est que
tous les autres sont quand même au moins
26 essais des bons 26 quoi au minimum il
est 25 vent dans le dos et qu'il soit
mis sur internet
après parente j'ai remarqué que dès que
tu te connectes il est connecté
il a pas l'air d'avoir une vie sociale
de haut et je tourne et tourne à bulles
est où l'arabie ravis que falcone qui va
être salée il a déjà perdu sept secondes
de salam salut et en plus sereinement et
leus moins fort cette seconde ça fait
mal ok des gens vont apporter plus de
3000 en solo c'est vraiment gros soucis
ok ça c'est la nuit que je joue avec b 6
donc l'idée ici c'est roy la suite j'ai
6 non non c'est parce que c'est là tu es
censé être un peu mon bien quelle vague
à dessein cnam et l'idée de péages ou 6
6 avant 1,6 ce qu'elle pourra jamais le
roi avec geci
ps1 courroye sur 18 après sa saisie
thème qui connaît mais juste ok
maintenant qu un kata en prison ok les
blancs sont juste mieux et là il y en a
quatre métaux quelqu'un l'a fait pas le
protéger au québec l'ensemble c'est pas
du médecin qui est prise je regardais un
truc comme ça marchait peut-être pas ça
c'est bizarre il veut reprendre du plan
mais toi contre x 50 cm les noirs bouche
bien pièce ils ont réussi à optimiser
les blancs raison pour laquelle des
hommes et les femmes à se planquer b3
qui est des quatre la jante et décalé il
ya tout comme jacques cattin menaces
persistent et on prendrait quatre kiev 5
peur et des ambulances faire très très
bon tu vois je me serais fait avoir
pareil parce que j'avais calculé juste
là et jusque là j'avais pas vu le dmg 4
mai et ouais route et 8 tabac il est
venu un vrai nom il avait rien eu mais
inquiet ça va sonner salem s'imagine
comment ils payent les sept secondes de
où il était chez pas où il était aux
chiottes ou non c'est parce qu'il a
foutu failli les paye cher parce que
s'ils à sept secondes de plus c'est pas
la même il doit pas perdre ça après les
petits tops de mauvais tours aux six
arrivées seconde 1 auquel elle paiera
auquel je pense qu'il a donnée âge pour
pouvoir se regrouper jouer vite
moi y avait juste prêt mais y avait
juste pas de raison c'est en fait les
positions bizarrement c'est mieux
d'avoir les blancs en bullet parce que
tu peux faire des échecs de loin oui
parce que je dirais le primove kanté
échec
or madame price un coup d'avancé aurait
bien tu es donc ils assez chaud parce
qu'il ya ce qu'il fasse prendre afrique
at il un retour d'investissement 60 ans
échoue battu
on y va et et alex à lèvres où il va
être salée salève bien revient il va
être salée ouais bon j'ai bien compris
comme ça non mais je la fais tout le
temps en fait c'est une blague
récurrente
ok ça c'est sensé déjà de l'union
problème blanche n'entend plus il se
prend des plages d'ouverture n'ai pas
senti dans la merde des cinq mosquées
prend hachette est aussi là tu obligé de
réfléchir parce que c'est tout ce que
tous voudraient pas toi le 4 4
il va se rendre kg cinq épreuves sur six
mathieu donne des faux conseils sympa le
même nom mais tu vois elle en plus qui
au rythme pour lui c'est qui paye
enfin il perd pas les trains y perd à
cause des sept secondes alain même les
noirs sont sortis c'est une commune au
tour de magie les noirs sont gagnants
mais c'est hyper facile à jouer en plus
avec les noirs mais par contre il a dû
résoudre des preuves dans l'ouverture du
coup que 10 secondes
ouais mais je pense que je préfère les
noirs mais malgré les 10 secondes de
retard
battus à mettre un bilan à cinq déjà et
puis arrive deux tours les sang et or à
chaque annonce et le soir c'est lui qui
se trouve fait c'est pas moi qu'il y en
a pour preuve ses shows a bien dû goûter
d'un hacker sykes et blanc bahia le
temps si tu prix montent un peu dans mon
estime se bouge bien mais qu est-ce qu
al mabhouh un les pièces qu'il a eu
raison de faire cet échange avec le
cavalier heroes des plus et là il peut
se compte des échecs regarde non mais
les deux ça se bat bien ton points à 6
oui bien que ça marche pas il va réussir
a souvent à tanger un temps très bien
joué watson mais à tanger cartman ans
qu'est ce qu'il fait il s'est planté
non m apparaît mais juste à temps mais
wade intense d'attendre maintenant le
monde
qu'est-ce qui fait l'un il a l'idée
loufoque et à leurs familles et
l'obscurité les oublies ton en v3
conséquemment n'y a pas des joueurs
comme dakar c'est à partir de demain
classée la qualif pour jouer contre eux
n'a qu'à et compagnie il va chez répare
donc demain il y aura un maximum en
s'auto n'aura bien sûr alors juste pour
répondre à l'ombre de caisses qui
arrêtent de dire s'il avait 16 secondes
de plus il aurait gagné la régulière
s'est jouée vite et la règle première
c'est la vitesse oui mais il arrivait
cette seconde en retard
ces emplois d'y passer lés stations de
bus et sept secondes de retard qu'il
avait à l'allumage parce que je suis là
bas je n'étais pas devant l'échiquier
mais pour ce n'est pas une question de
vitesse qua non honnêtement j'ai vu
personne vraiment soit au niveau de la
vitesse pour l'instant on apprendra pas
encore regardé pingouins alpin - qui à
mon avis au dessus à la souris oui comme
si rudi rabat les deux ena canon at elle
un cas aussi mais moins que moins
qu'avant il soyez moins fort que les
nouveaux gamin maintenant
l'essayiste et vieux un haka fabien elle
se fait déchirer cette rencontre loramyc
voilà c'est bien pris part à mickaël
rambur tu prends saute d'un échec
revient celui de cache cache et surtour
g1 ils peuvent être bien tu peux faire
fuji à ça rend fou quand il n'y a pas de
gain clair comme ça c'est frais c'est
juste qu'on les écoute il est un peu
mieux qu'à l'humain il rate fourchette
il a raté classée 2 a très bien joué le
cas des trois pré move
parce que le mec s'attendent à qui va
brûler le fou mais bon demain ça va
déménager mais déjà aujourd'hui se
qualifie pour son masque est bon c'est
fou que les blancs et pas gagné cette
année n'aurait pas gagné cette partie
plutôt oui mais là c'est bon un wiki et
ses deux prochains aux fourchettes
hockey est ce qu'on peut peut-être pour
la dernière change et que du coup le man
2 min match est fini ok donc du coup
portiques et prendre bien à temps
alors c'est vrai tu risques ont accès à
ce moment à jour alors attends
maintenant on a dude à addis emilia duda
qui a scoré dur aussi à cette annonce
qui viennent mettre un 4 0 25 ans sur
hansen
mais je ne connais pas tu me connais
mieux coupage de caunes et moi je le
connais personnellement et je le connais
pas en votre bulle est ce qui vaut sur
internet la fonderie l'impunité souvent
le dernier coup faisait 5 oublié
si c'est pas normal qu'un glaçon était
celui d'apprendre les 100 ml je peux
juste blandford qu'il faut aussi c'est
du mépris de ses très forts intenses
ouais attend quand même et ce qui n'a
pas dépensé 5 dans la new wave
fantastique et des 500 projets 5 très
bien je n aie le méprisent un peu comme
duda il mériterait de se prendre une
intro vie ouais enfin à force historique
à la fin tu prends pas le foulard
pendant quarante koussa et mme andré tu
peux te tue peut-on faire coller une
vrai t'as raison c'est par principe
quand votre adversaire jeu malvaës
punissez le faut pas chercher le bon
coup de
il avait huit tours b 8 nom n'est pas
tombé huit pardon et métiers à 11 ans et
huit noms mais pas ridicule
ils avaient tous des trois qui était
quand même bien que l'effort aucune
avant ça il faut des trois y avait
peut-être d'un français huit gars à qui
chaque jour à chaque parent ont des
attentes ou reprend et a fait la dame
qui va arriver
la tour qui arrive on sait cette mais ça
fait rien c'est comme une enseigne de la
table qu'il ait mis autant elle a deux
pièces de plus soit deux points de plus
aux besoins
ok donc le score 7e et demi heure et
demie
ouais mais d'où tu as tu vois on l'avait
enfin enterrée ouaip enterré juste et
les absents avaient du mal à se lancer
le coup du pâté vraiment bête ça non
plus
aya pâte à elle peut pas prendre ainsi à
purger non non le truc est dommage et
qu'en plus il se rend pas compte mais
hammers un de ses concurrents directs et
tapas loi du lait c'est alors à temps il
habitait qu'est ce qu'un attentat
bortnik doudane et pau feydeau 1 meur
vrai mais hammer et donne angle temps je
me sentais condé mais qu'il est que 2005
et avec ces mecs là et les pornic je
pense qu'il est 26 narcisse kiel et
26,50 sellem 26,80 meyer 26-20 monde
meilleur ces impayés des spéciales quoi
26 10 meilleurs il vaut mieux que son
classement envie de ça oui non mais déjà
son classement lui cédé 25 ans donc on
fait quoi on se dessine maintenant
ouais alors attendre que ce serait bien
qu'il ya un gros match le truc c'est que
moi je n'arrive pas à savoir où ce qu'on
peut faire en fait c'est attendre les
appariements les voir été décidée après
ouais ok on faisait environ 25 secondes
derrière les grilles aucun train de
green shoots critique honnêtement tu le
mets dans ce tournoi l'a vu comment il a
joué par sp défoncé un mes parents parce
que tu as noté qu'il a en tilt au
complet parce que tous les lancements et
l'enfant n'étant à hyper fort à la 40e
et tout et tout laisse la région ouais
je pense qu'ils en tilt complet mais
bonjour jean c'est plus que bien qu'il y
ait un entraînement de clics de souris
c'est plus compliqué que ça donc à temps
là on a eu quatre rondes pourri
donc il est tout est ouvert entre donc
sait c'est qu'un hyper intéressante
c'est ce que va tant mieux pour nous y
est pas quelqu un qui s'échappe
on avait un peu peur de sa toile à faire
un dépôt qui écrase os mais je le voyais
pas il est trop nonchalant pour l'e3 et
au nom épouse je voyais pas vrai non
regarde voilà je pense qu'on a le
classement le vrai classement parce
qu'ils avaient des parts mythique pas
fini tu vois le pingouin le pingouin
finalement
fait on raconte de la merde parce qu'on
n'a jamais les bons classements donc on
a quoi je trouve aussi je ne comprends
pas mini super beau en 20 minutes cc
c'est spécialistes c'est le mec il -
rédiger sa compétence mais c'est sa
spécialité je sais c'est un peu comme
les frères bryan en double au tennis
c'est comment ils sont pas mauvais en
simple je crois que j'avais entendu dire
que les maxis mettait vraiment hausse à
1,1 kg top 100 c'est quand même bien
mais ne s'est pas non plus j'ai du début
du jeu d'ailleurs moins nombreux dans un
gène exhibition c'est des gros génie en
développe un double acquittement devant
l'apathie du pin gouin ouest mais
j'aimerais bien voir un grand un contre
un et pau fait dossier pour l'instant
c'est ce que je dis ce qui
m'impressionne le plus
moi je viens voir une opposition de
style ou en pingouins fait d'elle ce
serait cool révèle au cfc choc des
cultures pour moi ce serait beau ça
comme match mais bon c'est qu'on devra
aller voir le pingouin les gens l'aiment
bien et tout est bien loin d'ailleurs
quand j'avais j'ai commencé j'avais cinq
minutes d'avancé sur un 10 minutes et je
me suis fait arnaquer par l'état gagnera
écoute moi je propose qu'on allait voir
pingouins hammer on voulait voir hammer
inquiète c'est que c'est par la fiche
qui te quitter le plus alléchante mais
c'est ça n'a plus de streamer laquelle
j'ai pas vu ce que c'était des autres
affichent donc choisi moi mais tu
choisis donc ok vous remarqué que dans
peau des mecs des bulles est il juste
souvent des petits répertoire comme ça
où les et a très bien joué bien des
plans y avait des quatre îles et
capitaux est un des cinq dernières 3 mai
froids bien jouer l'aller n'ont juste
pas de coup c'est le truc c'est l'enfer
mais pas de coût et en plus en bullet
n'a pas de coût et regarder secondes qui
s'égrènent matière a pas de courants
glacés l'enfer allende qui touche le
pion des chorfa cage est un game 7 6 car
il a vieilli il a lâché combien de temps
il a lâché 10 secondes 3 pour jouer à
six blessés
c'est ce que je pense que maintenant tu
as juste aurait la prison quelle
stratégie monde et 5 n'a pas forcément
envie des fois que des pions c3 mais la
juste peine avant développement photo la
position qu'elle g5 je pensais qu'il
était obligé bien je la présence et 6
intermédiaire car il existe et c'est ça
qui est ok donc l' identité et de matam
pour deux huawei mai 2005 il avait bien
qu'il avait pas vu d'ailleurs le choix
le carton les petites sort la carte ou
et le à ce qu'une amie
la fin est rien regardez c'est celle-là
il et 2014
non c'est quoi ton vis à dominance et
poker moi je suis 27,50 est bon dans le
dos je le défends moi moi aussi vendola
les 2007 mais tu as pour moi c'est pour
auquel attend encore le temps de jeu
qu'à 17,5 de bizarre dans lequel ils
sont parce que justement que ça gagne
pas une pièce comme nathan prend un
charme et de faire remarquer et 17 pour
un vainqueur et peut-être qui sait
jamais fait ça ça fait un an que l'on a
mais peut-être pas dans tous les cas sa
part d'hommes pions ok donc là il ya un
gros déchirage votre chance en fout des
deux d'abord vous fout des 2 à presque 3
fois 3 c'est m'attendent dans machete
poitrenaud ayasse et 570 d'en gagner en
hockey qu'il faut accroît ses cinq
grands poètes et des cinq très bien joué
mais tableau 7,1 à damas et de la mâche
ridha ben non ok mais là le pingouin il
peut y peu il peut faire des étincelles
quoi y'a des recettes matin quand même
pas non plus 25 au palais très loin aux
enfants en effet en se lavant dont six à
tora berger tout resterait mais oui
c'est par elle défendu quand même mais
on apprend des membres des deux os os il
est fort le paris - la france et de la
france est son nom il ya dan 17 matches
c'est chaud mathieu c'est pas le temps
de 10 secondes
il a plus de vie car chaque point pour
ces luttes intensité m'attends à 7
c'est chaud qu'elle et les blancs dans
les blancs donner une part entière ils
sont quand même mieux vous voyez cap
cana pense que les blancs vont gagner
ouais ça va jouer autant donc là on est
désolé si ça frise c'est le pas de ma
faute j'ai compris d'où venait le haut
le pingouin il est fort mathieu non il
va pas la perdre il va pas à 5 à 4
usain bolt qui montre qu'il est fort il
n'a pas perdu 2 ou non par contre on est
loin il s'est fait complètement des
chefs et là le mec ici d'un prof
pourquoi il a oublié que comme mais
bouffé la tour sa part m attendais cette
année c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire la défense parce que
défendre ça assez fou je la connaissais
la wla quel est le comble d'amr son fair
play
c'est dimanche soir pour aller bien
c'est intéressant ces structures avec
ses poings des séismes et aux il préfère
le voyage prend il va se retirer du
malheur 'l'annonce il va se prendre et
ça c'est le genre de truc qui joue mal
visiblement avoir pété un plomb frappe
dans les airs
wamala quebecers mauvaises annonces mais
je sentais qu'il allait se faire
déchirer droits à la retraite c'est soit
tu passes couverture soit ému a
également progressé un peu mieux touré
minutes qu'elle croyait dire il ya peu
des revenus après quoi il va s'affaisser
6 donc c'est pour ça que c'était bien je
de m
quatre tours l2 voire midi 4002 je dois
blanc j'ai deux ou trois sets pour f 16
les blancs sont nuls ok la petite
hippiques tranchantes
ok on apprend la première et on a même
sans caméra juste mieux parce qu'il est
meilleur mais ça suffit pas forcément
toi les autres le mec hyper ben affleck
arcade et 3 f 4 points c'est hyper bien
je viens les quatre années coup comme il
a amélioré sa position avec ailleurs et
manger 6,7 à tanger en phase iii pour sa
12ème pour une recette
voilà très très très bon et je suis chef
six tours 28 matches il le roi 3-1 je
serais jamais venu là moi je serai là on
veut trois persos pour 2 072 puis on
prend b3 roi reprend à même tueur mais
fou dessins que c'est hyper qu'on a pas
mais un autre réfléchie du coup mais
suivant il va être à deux et demi 1/2
alors que aux échecs maintenant mais ça
gagne tour des régions rebelles autour
des toros et trois autres des 3c catalan
voilà meurt il a décidé de prendre un
timeout fois de prendre un peu de temps
non non ça ne guette pas juste il a il
s'est fait une pause 5 seconde main
couvertures couleur ciel amarante il
tint a lieu un freeze vidéo pour
certains moi je regarde construit m'en
fait donc il ya eu zéro problème non
mais là ça va en fait j'ai identifié
pourquoi on avait des difficultés au
début du live est jeune on est désolé
l'homme des huiles et les blancs sont
vivement au bob le mans tours de francs
est assez qu il serait notamment pour
bizarre hein j'ai du mal à y va du
canton
c'est très faible peut-être que tu
deviens à tanger 8,3 à 30,1 n'ont
encaissé qu'un bien veut ça mais
post-humain mais ça tu peux faire g5
après parce qu'il ya des fous g5 c'est
bien ton g5 en fait le reste c'est faux
la recette cook et c7 ok maintenant faut
ramener ça le bonheur
et si je n'aurais jamais fait c'est un
vrai dire maison que un mur au dessus
c'est en inquiète chaque participant qui
placent carnac et autoradios plier web
en défense la somme en corse parce
qu'elle foute sont bienvenues et
secondes c'est pas loin à fin juin une
seule fois son cas veillez à 6 c'est
pour moi stratosphérique
mais en mai saint paul est regarde
autant on veille aux revenus importants
il est complètement revenu au temps et
dans le money time il est meilleur
ouais rémy les impressionner mais dès
qu'il a activé le cavalier la fête
fourchette incroyable donc là nous on
n'est pas sur mes 10 secondes contre 9
on pense qu'elle en fait c'est le
festival tango c'est incroyable mathieu
[Musique]
non plus soit il a il a tous les prêts
move il a failli exceptionnel ça son
métier il va m'en veux gagner autant
voilà planté un acteur exceptionnel le
pingouin mathieu à nouveau les trois et
demi un trois et demi en denis et il n'a
pas existé 1 heure finalement 1,7 et
partie des web et enfin mieux dans
chaque parti m
non mes vieux d'enchères parti mais je
leur dis que c'est à dire que le
pingouin activer un cavalier c'était
fini palmarès d'amr me prend une
fourchette quoi ouais moi j'imagine pas
la fourchette
la saint priest non mais incroyable mais
du coup au classement c'est à dire que
taïwan a hammer éliminé à mon avis
rameurs c'est finir donc moi je suis
pour aller au quai des gens va attendre
fedoseyev fait de seuil et bortnik on
n'a pas été impressionné
il avait fait son deuil me ou 3 ans
pendant la baisse lui ouais il avait
fait il avait joué contre saleh donc là
ils ont pas mis à jour tant qu'un
nouveau nom mais ce qui est sûr en fait
c'est que narre audit qui amorça les
meilleurs et en scène c'est finir ouais
bon surtout les deux parties donc du
coup moi je serai bien sûr big fish à
l'écouter on aimerait bien à munich
affiche pas moins à big non plus - c'est
une belle affiche alors il reste un peu
de polish contre la police dans le but
en or les polices dans le dur es salam
sall et qui remonte maintenant
malheureusement puisque je m'entends
dire est que dans notre équipier mais il
va il va avoir du mal honnêtement
mathieu ouais ouais je mets pendill est
très bon on glisse on l'a vu un jeu pas
du monde mais un bullet c'est vraiment
un truc à part un c pour si pour cela
qu'ils élèvent des petits jeunes ou des
gens qui sont vraiment spécialistes
peuvent faire quelque chose
alors demain donc demain c'est demain
c'est le sait les qualifiés du temps que
ces quarts de finale ça aux demi finales
grâce et quittent ces quarts de finale
de demain ses lecteurs de finale d'un
pseudo championnat du monde 2002 avec
elle en lice de nakamura greccio cas
rognant les mairies et qui d'autre kai
qin je pense donc de mars donc là ça se
joue sur deux jours la compétition
oui et donc samedi dimanche
moi je suis aux commentaires demain soir
aussi ouais demain préparer votre soirée
ça va être de 19 heures et je pense que
ce sera plus sympa demain honnêtement
mathieu encore qu'aujourd'hui dans le
sens où ce sera des matches on va suivre
mais j'aime bien le côté tout est ouvert
domaines comme ça mais je prêche aussi
ma paroisse mathieu alors je vais dire
pourquoi parce que j'ai fait un mail à
la suite des speechs s c'était en milieu
d'année
j'ai fait un mail au cio de tchatche.com
donc tu vois j'ai pris mon courage à
deux mains quoi et je lui ai dit le
format des speechs s faut faire un
format 7 ce serait beaucoup mieux il ya
plus de suspense et plus marrant et j'ai
écrit un et il m'a dit il m'a répondu eh
bah carrément répondu sur un belge et à
paris m'a répondu kevin ton idée
intéressante détail moi ton idée de 7
alors on avait parlé elle m'appelle dans
un live ouais donc je détaille l'idée
j'écris le truc et dis toi bien que ça a
été repris quasiment ligne pour ligne
pour le format d du championnat du lot
la non moins le seul truc qui m'inquiète
demain c'est que tu choisi de regarder
quel match ah mais ça va être les uns
après les autres
ac les uns après les autres à huy a
compris avec du coup c'est super ça
rassure ça explique demain cette
fantastique très bien présentement je
crée je suis en même temps ça veut dire
que demain il va y avoir un tina camurat
firoud déjà tu vois moi je suis très
curieux de mcafee roux déjà perso je
pense maca encore au dessus et après
comme tu dis il est moins bon quoi qu'il
en soit on en pleurerait chine est
encore devant nous tu as tiens regarde
le match mathieu été exaucé j'annonce
voilà pour moi c'est une sorte de demi
finales en fait s'il y en a un qui
écrase notre île est bien mais là c'est
vraiment l'opposition de style rêver
quoi c'est 5 un jour pour jour 2 5
donc vous voyez quand même n'ont pas
grandi à la décharge il peut se faire
déchirer mais en général je commence ses
propres les seuils sauf que là il le
procès qui peut se faire des chiens donc
de b3 la tête était de kg 5 bien fou
j'ai vite aller moi je me perds bien à
chis estime qu'ils donnent b 6 6 h des
souks cinquième aventure vous voilà face
il va tenter ça n'a pas d'âme des 6 kg 5
qui fera faut prendre
oui peut-être même 4 il y accueille des
4 vérités non non c'est complètement
jésus pour eux depuis sa tour f6 toi si
ce qui existe est le cahier pas enfermer
ouais mais tu t'es actifs de folie parce
que tu fais du tours fc soit tu reviens
et
allez il trouve les seuls couronne ok
pas rendre ça a joué hyper vite un ouais
mais c'est pas ça et encore la fête au
cfj fait une erreur à mon avis
gravissime
ces 10 secondes d'avancé au par mois et
un peu sans argent un commerce
oui oh la la quel génie ce pingouin
regarde il a incroyablement est déchiré
mais juste c'est le seul qui est bon et
ce en se formant pas le seul club et qui
maîtrise le format la perfection il fait
dans le sens que c'est le seul qui est
vraiment important
peut-être d'ailleurs on sous estime pas
parce que je le connais pas mais mais il
est la personne n'a raté pour un jeu de
pêche les mots de plus d'options de plus
ils gèrent tranquillement donc le
pingouin va gagner mais toi c'est
l'autre joue vraiment échec mais le
problème c'est qu'il ya moyen réfléchi
women le symbole ce rock voile et puis
quand il a réfléchi en plus du coup il
n'a pas en général en bullet quand on
réfléchit telle ou telle règle prend
très bien que les cages et qu'un tour
l'afo jeu pour ne pas en plus il a des
primes aux mains d'autres histoires de
ce très bon jeu
il est impressionnant ouais au
classement ça pourrait s'appeler du coup
moi je passe une porte munich alors
parce que c'est le seul qui peut le mali
vont ils vont se rencontrer les deux on
sait pas en fait je me sais pas trop ce
que c'est mais tu vois je suis pas non
plus étonné tu vois d'eric eric est un
peu de mal en bulles est sûre ça fait un
moment que tu as il joue moins sur
internet qu'avant et qu'il aimerait
jamais de bâgé métro et super bon il est
mauvais quant à fuji 80 sont bien mieux
fait de jeu pourrait être 5 woippy rock
cha rock fm en danger s'inquiète 2007
l'amf cet abandon
j'exagère mais oui adam détroit encore
mai
tellement de france qu'en retirent rock
a b1 b2 b3 et du tilt a il veut prendre
ses cassures échec à la mairie donne des
trois maintenant mais ok il aurait pu
faire plus fort ça c'est à tandem france
et je vois d'un processus échec tasse à
sauve un peu ouais et chante à un
prochain rendez vous est important et il
est abandonné direct c'était n'importe
quoi dans le lagon typique de notre
ambulance qui existent pas forcément
c'est le tilt là la dernière partie
c'est dutil a fait complètement
n'importe quoi avec les blancs dossier
il joue bien c'est ok bel essai c'est
une faute quand je crie elle reste est
ok ça savent encore ce qu'il a fait mais
il ya une partie fantastique de carson
jeunes dans ces structures
cheap au sort vient parce que tu sais il
est moins fort aux échecs
justin est meilleur en bullet ça déchire
end et des fois il déchire aussi qu il
me fait penser en bullet le pingouin
suisse à akwa un joueur de tennis sur
terre battue de céder spécialiste de la
terre sans trop longue j'ai dit mais qui
te renvoie toutes les vannes quoi
bruguera ouais c'est ça mais qui lui
quelqu'un te rajoelina et c'est toujours
le même il 30 fou du trafic et des 5èmes
bien voyez les quais prend les quatre
maintenant qui peut entraîner je le
ferai non mais honnêtement beach est
impressionnant quand même mais ça doit
pas suffire contre il peut pas prendre
du fou il a besoin d'eux pour bébé ouais
ouais c'est chaud là à damas on fermait
pas ouais incroyable mais bon texte et
sait même pas si quartier dufau de 5
c'est quoi le matin et qu'une tour à la
vraie mais enfin quand j 3
alors les femmes des cinq touchés trois
rives il faut
quand j'ai trois échecs tagging attend
il n'y a pas d'âme pour un f2 qui a deux
qui traîne 4la faut qu'ils jouent vite
par contre f5 j'aime pas du tout haspop
c'est bien joué qu'un complément des
quatre secondes ouais mais a su et ils
avaient davantage autant ils avaient
tous quoi je me rends pas compte à quel
point c'est facile de gagner en quatre
secondes
moi je sais que je tombe là c'est là
tout est très mauvais d'amd 14 précise
d'un ascète c'est ça c'est dommage pour
le calme ce qui mérite qu'un blanc
gagneront moins qu'une non mais la
feydeau seuil ffc avec machin il fallait
juste qu'il fallait juste accepté de
jouer une finale où un tout avec une
pièce de moins elle a gagné il avait dix
secondes de plus autant il a manqué de
lucidité là mathieu may et moi je pense
elle a manqué de bullet time
mais bon là c'est 3 c'est bien pour les
blancs main à dans un an il ya qualifié
donc ça c'est pas clair mais le truc
c'est que ça doit de fertilité souhaité
qu'un 27 30 tu dois sentir que tu joues
mieux aux échecs mais tu vois que le mec
il est spécialiste de la surface et qui
te et qui te balades quoi il se fait
souvent balader mais juste la mecque
ils n'auront jamais dans ce sens la
palanque sens unique dominée géré dans
le centre où tu sens que tu as plus
d'échecs mais ça nous arrange toi moi je
serais un quatrième film avait arnaqué à
grains quand j'étais gagnant en 10
minutes mais pétain car il est bon non
mais là les noix en plus domine et
qu'après bien beau temps pourtant vaches
qu'elle ses trois cahiers des singes et
ronan des casses toi par contre 10,5 à
bien jouer il faut faire 105 très bien
retrouver presque moquée de l'étranger 4
à tapis en encore peut-être qu'il
fallait tourner à mort un jeune en
gagnant ce qu'on puisse le cavalier rudd
la pendule à disneyland avance donc là
ça un 4 0 qui fait très mal parce que
c'est contre un adversaire direct
oui c'est pas fait encore le 4-0
intentions le 2d 2 2 bah tu choisis ton
en deux mots justes c'est marrant mais
c'est pas ma droite schiste a qu'un
échec de l'autre côté c'est matt à 4 040
ouais ouais ouais ouais démonstration
mathieu le pari en démonstration
aillagon
est-ce que stream c'est possible qu'ils
stream en même temps il est capable mais
il parle d'un titre hymne organes un
truc comme ça il va me sa dépendront des
mecs aussi bon nom mais qu'on touche
packard prodige petter contre un autre
contrôle n'est pas tant la quatrième
meilleure en scène le match et quand
vous voulez mais qu'il faut à 2h40 qu il
ya deux ans pour mener pour comme ça on
voit un peu le peuvent
le score alors il ya un maire qui stream
en scène stream neurostream et c'est
tout donc polish fighters bas pour le
2-2 il est un peu manga en un temps et
un plein de plus en finale de temps
j'aimerais pas jouer une finale le
torrent bull est mon tour j'ai deux et
puis on prend un f3 qui va la guinée lé
coût de 2,2 du coup c'est très bon
copain
c'est un coup de tora de ges trois
cannes séjour royal tente à neuf se
monte à permanent on va prendre le temps
de faire droit c2a les fautes profession
est à 9 secondes ne pas avoir jugé à
tort jeu de boca ton jeu de ménages et
iii après du post
c'est pas bien doodle il n'a pas les
automatismes du truc il détrône aille
encore battant faut aller voir bortnik à
la prochaine parce que tu as quand même
porter on parle du pingouin meta bortnik
impressionnant
à mon avis ça fait un ça va jouer s'est
même pas mon avis ça va se jouer entre
pornic et pas moins et un dépôt il est
quand même ray à moins qu' un duel n'est
pas au bar dick a mené au dépôt faut
quand même les gens j'ai passé sous le
nez peau c'est juste le meilleur joueur
d'échecs de de la table ans il est top
10 mondial mais vous êtes tellement il a
monté j'ai vu récemment sa va pas
suffire à mon avis mathieu auquel on
combien ronin was a perdu contenant
attend il en reste on en a fait six noms
quel est ce que les mecs dans le château
nous dire quel roman nation moi j'avoue
que je dirais six mais je suis un peu au
niveau de leurs ça correspondrait sus
quelqu'un si l'ennui 10 joueurs
six joueurs de tiers ouais on na vi et 6
6 7 8 9 fois et sauves at 6 6 7
est-ce qu'elle s'est mis à jour et
classement type en sauna ok bah on est
obligé de supporter pékin parce que même
si j'ai moins le profil pente je sais
même pas à quoi il ressemble ça doit une
cette non parce que regard 5,5 x 4 20 24
tu penses qu'il a dit cet ennemi sur 24
ou 17 et demi sur 28 raid s'était mis
sur 24 ça doit être ça près sinon il ya
là la probabilité de tout additionner
les bords points je vous laisse faire on
a attaqué la tête
en fait il a 17 ans qu'il ya une erreur
sur le classement c'est attendons
s'attend comme et nous on n'a pas de
parti en courant ça veut dire quoi 7
aucun problème de ce corps pour
pingouins c'est possible mais ça c'est
pas de notre 21 c oncernant tu as
récupéré les scores officiels
grâce à sa fille ciel donc il est
remonté à 17 c'est juste qu'en fait ils
mettent du temps à mettre à jour au live
ce qui est pari fou parce que c'est
tellement simple de mettre un autre
ouais en fait c'est un fichier puis
ouais ils ont deux points d'avancé
un poison est donc née peau qu'on a un
bon terreau et d'impôts il peut encore y
aller par contre fait de ses gaffes le 4
0 je pensais à c'est fini c'est dans la
tête en bleu sont ils étaient à égalité
c'est terrible on ne sait meilleur ok
bon le problème de connexion internet et
en scène ouais il est peut-être
ok donc on fait comme tout à leur faut
pas suivre
on regarde ce qu'il ya ensuite les
probablement bortnik probablement pornic
ou alors teg si je vous contraint et pau
elles sont là on va regarder la tête
bon on va dire d'être au premier on
regarde l'appariement pétrole à l'a7 et
fini ok donc
donc on va attaquer la 8 donc ils
attendent et mervans 19 n'ont pas encore
commencé là c'était des gens qui
classent n a pas commencé regarde les a
marqués lahidji a marqué 7 fini non je
pense qu'il est il à la rue celui qui
écrit ça il en reste trois arrêts il en
reste 3 on peut peut repêcher un perdant
avec bas on peut pas faire ce qu'on peut
mais ces raisons c'est sympa c'est sympa
combien on est con mais en es tu sais
pas mais on est dans les 170
mais aujourd'hui on n'avait pas de
premières pages donc c'est notamment un
but de maxime qui joue le top mondial
n'a qu'à car yakine une grille ciocca
mevel qui a fuit rhodia qui s'est
qualifiée il ya l'argentin que je ne
prenais pas et le vainqueur aujourd'hui
tout ça dans le manqué de choquer un
classement qu'on m'envoie mais est-ce
que ça ouais ok moi je vois un peu qui a
joué contre eux qui l'attend je vais
dire le pingouin il lui reste narrow dit
ce qui est en scène ou wii favori et il
lui reste tout à fait d'os eev en scène
ben je sais pas 37 mois moeurs que
c'était la ronde avant ok ok mais le
classement est en train de se remettre à
jour là j'ai vu les lignes bouger en ça
n'est pas ça si ce nom mais ça change
pas devant les gens je suis maître un
jour le dernier truc
ok donc plus porte nicolas alors
attendez pour attendre qui doit jouer
meilleur en fait meilleure est ce que
chaque mais chez les meilleurs jeunes on
les a maîtrisés pour l'instant la
regarde les images donnent alors attends
il ya pingouins ok la partie contre 1 -
polish ouais moi je me regarderai
morning parce qu'on a il mérite la paix
contre saleh l'a vu dans quel est le
truc c'est que l'entrée en titre voilà
après oui regardez il a déjà du retard
au temps et je vous ai chèque je le fais
n'importe quoi et josé socrates et l'a54
avec les blancs d'un imaginaire c'est
quand tu peux jouer n'importe quoi
enfin ce réfléchis tu le plante quand
même quoi bref je fous des quatre gammes
projet 7
ok grand roque l'affairé gaffié à s'être
bien jouer sa part longtemps pu l'être
c'est ce que je prends pas les noirs ici
à 6 6 dans mes deux oreilles la
république qu'il aurait pu sentir
ok super bien été jours à l'a6a les tons
quotas ont fait mal au temps sec l1 lens
y joue sans réfléchir
un génie fou bekkat dans les peut créer
un réseau de bots tour ouais mais là il
s'essaye il s'est pris tous les prêts
vous
si tu veux 4 d'abord cette game a remis
les rênes à cause des raids il est raide
à la pendule quoi s'est fait martyriser
temps des six matches impressionnant
quand il est mal
il est malin ouaip et en plus il s'est
hissé que le tournoi est fini pour lui
entre guillemets donc là on regarde
porte ni pourquoi parce que ben il est
en tête et un style tout ce que je
n'aime pas mais on s'en fout mais ça
marche
à l'étagé pas journée comptant au 18e
couillard que celui-ci seconde a
réfléchi je suis passé tellement de
temps de bouger la souris d'affaires c6
b5
c'est fou les cinq c'est comme un coup
catastrophique de bullet je les laisse
le this is de 5,1 tu prends mais si
c'est la colonne c'était mieux
ta premier coup il a fléchi de la partie
je pense que c'est très bien le piège
je pensais que ça marchait pas faux de
cet art mais pourquoi ne peuvent pas
peut être quatre j'ai eu mal j'aurais pu
quelle étrange je crois que s'il avait
gâté de cfa va là bas non il est pas
moins violente en a trois très bien je
vous donne maintenant ramène la donne en
fait trouvé par web os mais t'as vu leur
garde a fait toute cette tempo quand il
a su que c'était fois justin qui fasse
et je crois pas la troisième fois nous
puissions non c'est un sport bild
s'il faut demander à faut demander c'est
pas automatique
chris pts 5 pour prendre congé cette
saillie par la guerre infosys amat main
ça m'a pas du tout euros ht et angers 7
avant 17 h 8
il raté dans la suite incroyable dans la
chute d'un premier c'était une attente
de ben ali était sûr qu'il y avait un
clouage ou un échec mais vérifie tout de
suite tu peux pas ouais ça va ça allait
couler combien de temps il reste
quelques secondes dans ses passes et
encore moins si ouais mais parce qu'il
avait la quête et le pré mouscron b 6
il avait dit allez le trouver si c'est
là
il a tout lu foot en idle quoi c'est
aurélie rastoul étions c'est fini là je
veux dire il après movie l'après ouvre à
ses quatre par machin il a tout près
vous la chine inquiète j'ai pas eu le
temps de mais je crois que je crois
qu'il y avait un danger de cette hand à
manger pour enjeu de j'avais damages qui
était jacques tord achètent des princes
ah oui oui non tu as raison exacte ok ça
c'est l'une théorique il faut 17 c'est
pas le bon bout ses pions temps 1 4 la
banque ou bon ils font n'importe quoi
non nos deux abandons vous et les 800 ha
les m15 échappe encore à oui ok j'avais
5 fu trièves croient s'aimer pris un
bien dont souffrent et de maquettes à
l'est de là c'est le tilt à sept de
suite on va arrêter de regarder c'est
parti non mais tu pourrais horrible pour
lui c'est que enfin là il n'y a pas
perdu en corse à la whey dit non oui en
effet il souvent titre on est d'accord
par ok t'as échec serait 8e effet qu'est
points des quatre tempo bien jouer dame
de poule b 5 peut-être donc la forme
ennahda mois atteint 3,4 faire un truc
dans le 6ème mois six abandons toi aussi
ci pourrait faire vous pouvez faire d'un
mètre quatre échecs aussi je pense qu'on
peut pas changer la saône allemand il
faut pas regarder six pingouins une
chance de revenir en fait il faut
regarder si elles chanteront venir parce
que le port tenue qui déchire tout
pingouins qui perd quand police qui perd
pour le moment
du coup polish arbitre la finale parce
qu il lui reste à jouer aussi notre
ouais c'est dommage c'est dommage pour
politique en fait s'il fait 3 enfin on
va avoir un messi bat c
maman vtt et de patent ouais il avait ya
vraiment pas été réaliste elle se prend
deux déjà être déjà un point de plus de
buzz et moi je dois voir ça ça me donne
envie de voir des speechs s avec des
nouveaux mais qu il a peut-être raté sur
cet échec un terme et ouais mais tu peux
difficilement me paraît un peu tôt pour
connaître mon côté parce qu'on n'ose
dire poliment
après c'est pas si facile beauté matin
je sais matin ouais c'est tout reste
sept matches après tu peux jeux dessins
qui est ici de bouger notre tour
métallique est arrivé un cavalier mais
il est capable de se faire arnaquer non
rien de temps non je pense que de daara
beaucoup de regrets parce qu'il a très
bien ça il avait pris mon mal tourner si
cette date les touristes guise d'appât
on ne comprend pas trop sékou toure file
à l'essai doit s'activer à quoi ça
servait à rien de temps à sa
petite-fille d'un joueur belette ça mais
bon mais il faut le temps tu es c'est
notre seule chance de gain battant on
retourne chez pornic
du coup trois en termes polis chant et
si bortnik venir à perdre celle là pas
étonnant qu'il ait mis autant que moi je
pense que je re que or seulement le
chichon way or bortnik basse et
l'ailière je pense qu'ils n'en reste
plus qu'une ou deux rondes et resteront
au classement 1 et peut-être mis un gros
score mais pas plus caucasiens ont
manqué normalement il est censé avoir
deux points de retard à ben ouais mais
ça se rattrape mais lien marot
tiens on va voir meilleur pouvoir un peu
c'est cette annexion
regarde connaisseurs ok il est
déconnecté est meilleure avec les
allemands ils n'ont pas de connexion
mais ils ont fait une fleur
le mcs a eu de la peine à peine meilleur
attend un bon joueur après je pense
qu'il est mort est-ce que tu penses
qu'il faut que j'anime la lumière ouais
tu peux y aller dans la pénombre si je
devais recevoir ma nouvelle devait
recevoir ma nouvelle lampe aujourd'hui
finalement le livreur en sueur
c'est incroyable j'ai hâte de voir la
mise à jour donc du coup qui à koné peau
qui peut sauver cet ukrainien dans le je
pense qu'il va falloir retourner voir le
match de portiques de toute façon parce
que ça se joue là ainsi wade est entre
les mains
[Musique]
ouais dans le spécialiste
il a mais combien sont aussi rappelle
3000 quel saint nous avait 3000 et
calque désolé lien pourri alors pas
moins compte 37 avec le pingouin en
jouant en scène vrai mais le truc c'est
que même si fait 4 0 mélanie laurent est
ce qu'ils sont bons mais classement ce
que vous pouvez nous confirmer
je pense qu'ils n'en savent pas plus que
nous bright à pornic police fighter qui
est parti on a on n'a pas vu j'ai besoin
dans les années 50 ans
ouais parce que parce qu il a encore
prouvé que il est hyper fort parce qu'il
a mis un g6 et pas mates encore non
c'est n'importe quoi ça commence avec -
bientôt follow up et samatan plus blâmer
les vernis ce soir ouais les commandes
et les planètes s'alignent ouais là il a
tout pour lui la bombe à montillot l'a
finalement j'aime bien c'est un fou
c'est qu'à quelques coups de merde faut
trois parmi les bruits les bons éléments
ont déjà cette jeune et nagui dix bornes
nick est ce que les gens peuvent nous
dire un set son nom là je fasse
n'importe quoi est ce que cannes est un
switch ou vos globes non non et non
j'ai peut être un de ces quatre
le temps s'ils me posent pas mal olala
regarde c'est parce qu'il existe ou s'il
tétouan s'est passé est maintenant je
trop faible mais par contre j'aurais pu
jouer les qualifs mais juste je préfère
regarder un film et non honnêtement
gueullette c'est pas mon truc autant
froisser sting et quand il ya du vent
quinze minutes je fais des panthers mais
j'ai jamais été mon compte sur ce point
comme il est vraiment récent je joue
rarement je me suis dit que vraiment à
sa main est aussi fou des quatre fins et
roye b 4 qui avaient leurs meilleures qu
est ce qu il a fait sensation il ya 22
ans bortnik hockey est en fait je
l'avais vu parce qu'ils jouent là ils
avaient jusqu'à dimanche pour un espace
fermé à tort il avait jugé pas du
moindre grain il avait été assez bons il
était dans l'hérault cette blague dont
il est vrai c'est tout 25 90 passes
depuis 96 dresse un mec qui peuvent plus
trop jouer mais qui kiffe le bit soit
assez impressionnant coeur parce que
c'est fascinant chez les courtiers
ce qui est impressionnant c'est qu'en
fait ils plantent des grosses tactique
quand c'est chaud et puis quand c'est
moins sûr tu as l'impression qu'ils
jouent un peu à l'économie tranquillou
et après ils trônaient il mais la
tactique
ben ça donne trop envie de se dire qu'il
a fait les tournois officiels et des
bateaux maintenant donc c'est dans ton
coin de sa marche pas je voulais finir
le teaser assez surprenant ça c'est bien
pour les blancs ça marche pas c'est un
mythe en clair tu auras 4 c'est bien
j'ai trouvé 4035 points échec
ça joue bien ça joue bien
un moment émouvant par des cap sinon la
tour et enfin m ce que j'attends de me
dire 9,3 et skate à l autogestion
stocker assez bien joué qu'il commence à
le dominer temps prendrait 5 au prochain
à kg 4 maintenant carte
non je pense que ça perd pas on nous dit
que c'est un peu cruel un qualifié ouais
mais le truc c'est que en fait la wii
genre de suite il ya des qualifiés qu'à
non il faut aussi voir que dans les mecs
qui ont pas eu à jouer avec les qualifs
puisque taux final tata huit personnes
qui vont être dedans mais tu as ta
nakata mvl moi je pense il ya que great
yoka plus - qui a plus sa place comme
avant parce que c'est pas il a failli
les plats génération des bulles est
apolitique et qui a fait un truc type ia
tura 7 c'est dommage qu'une science un 3
bet
non je crois qu il enfin mais allez donc
un nul de ski néanmoins bien l'otan vous
menez qui prend la nuit là je pense il
est content là bas que pingouins à
carnac
bah ouais ouais mais ça c'est vraiment
des c'est pas les jours d'un café ce
genre de boulette c'est un truc
différent les mecs ils font ça en 20
minutes dont 15 mm 5 cd votre café là
c'est différent tu sais je ne sais pas
le jeu je comprend pas du tout pourquoi
porter qu'il a prises hors norme en faut
prendre de g je pense qu'il connaît rien
de ce que tu peux prendre tout ce que tu
veux
la main quatre abandons en gros problème
contre les forces et qui peut ne pas
passer les quinze coups il s'est fait
aux caisses à relancer un peu le tournoi
peut-être a dit vas-y vas-y ben du coup
on attend peut-être que vous en finisse
avec un verre faut aller voir pingouins
surtout comme ça on va voir le score de
0 0
blanc elle est dans le dur pour acheter
maintenant de hockey ça coûte cher ça
coûte rien même pas moi c est sauf et il
a perdu contre policiers et l'aï lâché 1
point contre 1,100 a pas le droit en
fait c'est dur à dire ça mais c'est vrai
je les joue pas le rock quand j'ai vu la
qualif d'un voyage tu te tue consommer
qu'un le niveau du tournoi mathieu pour
dire que en scène lâché un point c'est
enfin tu vois c'est choquant
ouais ouais ouais donc né pauvre dépôt à
finir de trois ça ouais ouais mais tant
qu en fait le truc c'est que il a et le
truc bête et qu'il a toujours été bien
placé dans les deux tournois hier et
aujourd'hui
mais jamais premier
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas mérité l'on
m'appelle cassé rampe est un combiné toi
tu en penses quoi ça une place pour le
combiné la mecque il a fini sur le
podium les trois fois non j'exagère
peut-être 230 de surcroît je pense c'est
déjà énorme et laurie y aurait pu avoir
une wild card à la fin qui décidez de
vrais une place au cumul et ça tu
pourras alors proposé parce que ya pas d
âge qu'on s'est loupé
mais ça c'est pas si fort en mai à la
primaube d'abuser c'est beau quel point
c'est qu'elle combine non tout reprend
la dame décide défend la tordre ellis
c'était joli trait ok c'est pas encore
bien le quai faut qu'il fasse bien fait
par exemple parce qu en scène c'est un
peu le même style c'est le même site que
le pingouin en moins fort ça va très
vite à la sourire mais look et les moins
bien en temps mais juste question à
rognan ils savent pourquoi dans sa pas
terrible
honnêtement tu vois c'est un peu dommage
well par exemple à rognan je trouve ça
un peu dommage qu'il ait une place dans
le sens où franchement il est moins fort
que le pingouin
je pense c'est sûr regarde même grille
tout qui se fait ici est choqué il est
en dessous bref on l'a vu mais je sais
pas si les gens se rendent compte
dams et si c'est plus perpète les gens
ce qu on compte hier dans les qualifs
défectueux qui avait un rêve y avait des
faux seins et pochepa sûr mais il ya
visité la russie mais qui ne le savent
pas s'ils vont donc à temps et ce qu' il
reste encore 1 meur 2 cf
trop trop pure et bah il a imposé en mai
10 effet il s'est pris tilt et en bullet
d'apple normal mais je t'appelle raconte
que je veux bien du tournoi s'il était
une 3e ou 4e à trois ans de la fin et il
a il a pris un une pause au dos je
regardais pas non mais en fait il y
avait le roi f4 et les tours congé 2 en
1 et c'est juste que lui s'attendait pas
la fatigue s'ajoute pendant ce tournoi -
j'ai pas trop l'habitude comme toi mais
donc wife 5 lapierre coeur tu prends ton
des quatre procès beau nom mais je pense
que ça te fait tilter quand les mecs qui
te met des pièces en un et que tu as
juste pas le temps de prendre quoi c'est
horrible c'est un truc gameiro f3 pas
très il a explosé
c'est très con way 6-3 en attente de
cinq ans d'apprendre à l'école ça 3 4
août ouais c'est triste pour pour big
fish et non le classement s'il te plaît
ouais alors attends donc born in 24
ils n ont pas tu peux lui promettre un
jour je crois qu'ils cela je sais pas
mais j'imagine
du coup il reste qu il va rester
il reste plus nous devrons maintenant
j'habite c'est une hausse 0,8 je crois
non je me suis même pas sûr ellis coup
les tops gm sont là pour attirer donc
bah oui et bien sûr tu as raison que ce
soit when i museau ses doigts et c'est
ça mais dans un sens si tu as déjà naka
naka envel
d'ailleurs c'est pas si bête ce truc de
cali par exemple pour moi il ya une
grosse erreur dans notre succès le guèye
le mec il se qualifier en gagnant le
premier temps - c'est le plus dur la
première chance qui tue je fais je conte
de maka ouais ça ça aussi j'ai trouvé ça
concerne aujourd'hui pour moi c'est en
se qualifiant en premier ils devraient
avoir le choix par rapport aux autres
exactement ce qui se qualifie en dernier
c'est humain
quel show 3 ça fait trop tourner les
scènes quelqu'un qui arrive à larache au
dernier est par exemple sera peut être
le mec déjà qualifiés qui gagne non
parce que du coup en fait le premier
qualifié il joue n'a qu'à le deuxième
qualifié il joue mvl qui sont quand même
censé être les deux plus forts mais
maxime je suis intéressé ma demande
façon on suivra le match mais ce pont
d'iena normalement c'est censé être le
premier tour de rêve enfin vu les
monstres là que tu peux prendre et donc
une coupe dimanche les demi finales
finale sapin mouais ça va être pour moi
et bien sûr alors non côtoient c'est
qu'on s'est bien passé mais rationneront
6 il en reste une blessure bord tenir
bon bah ça joue en fait savoir
classement du coton mais j'ai pas bien
vu du coup au classement mon jeu c'est
fini ou pas il a trois points d'avance
tranquille attendant il a besoin de
points
il a déjà gagné la première donc balle
de match ban ne maintient pas de porte
nique j'ai dit si c'est important
qu'elles 4,6 était prêt si besoin de
gagner et espérer jan 4th 4 qui donne un
petit arrangement union confie mathieu
mais du coup pour parler un petit peu
aussi dûe à il peut pas un poil une fois
ce cap mais dormir
vas-y tu disais je disais qui est favori
d'après trân aka gros favoris ou avec ce
que tu m'as tu appuies obtient non
ménaka parle pour lui en général pour
pour la face c'est bon c'est encore trop
tôt par tourner à caffiers rouge à
tuchan quoi ça en contrepartie je crois
que c'est en trois sets gagnés en deux
sets gagnants sur aix en deux sets
gagnants les sept premiers à 6 c 1 500 a
paru être le tennis 6 4 6 4
ou alors c'est en une demi-heure à temps
je pense que ça ce que je te dise et les
règles pour la plage pour la troisième
place je vais te regarder ça assez de
produits de bullet non-stop pour les
pour les quarts dans ses trente minutes
non stop aux mais avec 30 mais le sénat
du coup il peut y avoir du jeu jusqu'au
bout mais c'est pas comme on glisse
parce que là tu veux la veille et ça
marche pas il ya r4 et en rachetant il
ya plus tangermed
mais c'est quand même comme s'il était
complètement gagnant actuellement
mais bon c'est là qu'il est il peut
faire les heures il est humain il était
tellement gagnant autant j'ai même pas
eu d'ailleurs plus s'ils avaient
anticipé le cavalier chèque de paye et
notamment mes félicitations c'est
alexander bortnikov place et ben ali a
cependant atteint et il a fait qu'il a
vu deux derniers jours oui il a joué il
a joué et même une autre après tu es en
forme aujourd'hui tu vois la maj 2 j'ai
planté ce piège c'est pas mal d'enfants
inadaptés
est ce que c'est cette l'enfer à cinq
mètres en courant et du coup d'argent
tania pas un sacrifice
alors demain c'est à quelle heure c'est
la même heure c'est 19 heures 19 heures
19 heures à 19 heures 23 heures à 23
heures une bonne soirée
alors attendez main pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que ça dure quatre heures si on a
les quarts de finale céline damien un
jeu comme en bas à c'était les huitièmes
de tous non ces quarts de finale
mixant ne sait pas même le même quart de
finale c'est ronan malheur c'est que ces
quarts de finale de mixage raconte
n'importe quoi ce que demi finale c'est
60 minutes 1 mais c'est pour ça que
dimanche n'a que deux heures et je
savoure son bain bleu 1 n'était pas ce
que le truc en cinq sets la finale ça va
être super long parce que c'est en cinq
sets gagnants en trois sets gagnants
il ya un match pour la troisième place à
à la suite
ouais passagers avec des opus
d'un autre côté il ya des dépôts je
pense à te dire et je veux pas tous en
même temps peut-être ouais c'est ça
ouais ils vont page en même temps est-ce
qui est mien parce que honnêtement le
défaut de sport c'est la visibilité à la
piste donc c'est c'est mieux
- pour nos compagnes poursuivre la
compétition terme soit deux abandons à
bouche la langue
c'est incroyable comme un système à
temps de 1 min guyot temps qui est
peintre émérite de l'apprendre ça n'a
pas un besoin 2e rep au troisième tout à
fait honnêtement pas de surprise non
seule déception et le cf qui a implosé
en vol l'occasion je suis quand même
surpris de portiques tang 1er 2e tu vois
moi je suis mme et épuré plutôt penser
un dépôt employés pas qu'ils allaient
les po2 d'abeilles sont 3,4
un joaillier alors je la voyais dans
l'autre sens sur un joaillier peut-être
né porte nick doux date en goûtant que
duda tu vois mais ça n'a pas été si bon
on est dedans il fait pas mieux que de
temps en temps dans votre garde toi
l'été dernier
ouais mais je pensais que tu sais avec
le qu'on appelle le le fait que le droit
soit très dense que ces joueurs là
finalement ils fassent aussi parler
l'habitude tu vas jouer des guépards
numérique nous ont levé les pins pas à
septembre on le croyait podium dont je
le voyais podium je sais que ces
spécialistes c'est son truc tu là un
portique voyez jamais gagné tu vois je
ouais mais je ne le connais pas donc
peut-être que c'est quand même temps
quand même pas que c'est le même niveau
sur internet c'est pas faudrait demander
ce genre ah mais qu'est ce qu'ils en jeu
des matches déjà
il ya un loyer moyen de rechercher
pouvoir remplir passé les bortnik j'ai
déjà vu mais il m'a jamais paru aussi
fort que ça où est-ce qu'on pose la
question qui fâche est ce que c'est
possible de tricher en bullet
bah ouais théoriquement c'est possible
mais là franchement je crois pas la sas
et ça c'est pas jouer il dit peut-être
que c'est maka qui joue à sa place
un haka si tu veux c'est pas trop de
gens 3 des cadeaux le set au tennis est
ce qu'il y aura deux points d'écart à
6,6 belle j'imagine que oui oui oui ce
sera pas un tie break ce sera deux
points d'écart béton web comme un tie
break mais j'ai bien à hélices et je
retournais bortnik comptant celle ci
tombe en date après mots webber entamait
la très forte que je pense que quand ils
sont pas deux phases un gros si on
arrive à passer ici faisait dos et est
maintenant deux ans il s'est cru que
c'était dame pat/me le mal-vivre
finalement il a eu les planètes aligne
aussi les portiques ça fait un peu
penser au nom du méchant dans sonic et
je pense qu'il continue m à cette vidéo
sur youtube mettre en lien de dans ma
partie contrôlé il ya quatre ans mis à
jour et le chat
bon ça récupérer une truc qu'on soit
bien le chat
robotnik ouais c'est robotnik dans mamma
mia pourquoi les dix plus à un jour de
robotnik et je suis hyper médiane a été
bon et je n'y réfléchis pas en fait il
fait peu de gaffe ils voient les
magouilles permis aux qu'ils ont les ont
dit qu'ils ont jusqu en 30 secondes l'un
contre l'autre a commenté tard chercher
comment non c'est bine cause qui est le
chat un nom à ce que pingouins on peut
remonter alors mis en vigueur
maintenant est ce qu'on dit sur qui a pu
ré que ça joue plus la balle a ouais
parce qu'en fait moi j'ai pu sortir ce
point comme il y avait dans le chat un
mec il disait que c'était vrai ce que
c'est classement final du coup la grosse
domination de pornic étant finalement
les spécialistes un renardeau mais après
est-ce que tu penses baca mais comme des
bosses et un peu démoralisés quand ils
voient qu'ils publient
cette salle est l'arabe falcon 43,1 me
noyer on l'a suivi pas trop mais bon
vous pouvez pas tout faire à pingouins
métro ce match sur youtube ils ont
trouvé 4 400 contre 1600 pour pingouins
sur les pièces séparent ils ont fait ce
qu'ils ont fait ou attendre plainte l'un
contre l'autre en 30 secondes
ben ça c'est vraiment un spécial et du
coup j'avais dans ce cas là c'est à dire
que brad mais qui est vraiment je me
sens pas impossible en 30 secondes
la partie setchine ans
ça fait quoi ça fait miller eric
tellement déçu son stream arif et 8 en
plus sans vraiment existé dans son juste
le dernier match et faire un bon match
ou non aimé me déguiser le bon match
enfin quand bortnik à gagner le match
fortier qui mène 2-0 quand il a gagné la
qualifie tu vas tu veux dire il se fait
sans heurt mendy fait sans heurts il
faut fut rien mais du coup je suis en
train de me dire quand ça non plus ouais
il finit devant meilleur mais ferme à
palmarès de meilleur j'ai pas de
connexion internet à bord optimale in
the storm asseoir connexes sur ses
terres et les options rien à
l'impression dans les premiers huawei du
coup ça va être intéressant
franchement ça dommage qu'ils appellent
le wac a pourtant mes parents furent aux
ja je suis hyper content moi j'ai
enregistré espérer que ce soit plutôt
tendre qui se qualifie et les filières
100 m me disant avec le mec que je ne
connais pas peut-être qu'il sera
impression comme mortes nus cochonneries
d'ailleurs c'est même possible parce que
pour gagner dans ce tournoi c'est un peu
le même profil 1 oui non mais ça le mec
s'est qualifié c'est un peu le même
profil que les dollars l ordinateur mais
tu vas fuir ou déjà en fait fuir ou déjà
séduit ccc le mélange parfait quoi c'est
à dire mais il est jeune il est bon aux
échecs et en plus il a ce truc de bullet
de la génération de port beach est
autant un taux c'est pour ça moi je suis
demain franchement le match n'a
qu'affirment certains pour naka logo ds
que ça commence par celui-là alors ça y
est j galko à la joie tous les khalifes
il était toujours dans le top 10 et il
n'y a jamais eu une chance fuit rosières
pourra donner un peu de monde oui je
pense clairement je connais pas mal un
peu l'iran annonce que j'entraîne la
numéro une iranienne a - à part les
bandes il ya un peu un peu dans sa bulle
il faut qu'il parte avec son père on
s'en va tout seul il pourrait pas
trouver votre verdict non plus avec la
génération avec parme là que je connais
moins d'une heure il travaille il ont
l'aide de l'état
ils ont des bons entraîneurs ils sont
hyper motivés font que ça déjà après bon
pour moi c'était la génération ce
rapport car ça ne soit encore là et
c'est donc ça va être chaud mais non
mais tu vois ce qui me qui me ce que je
suis en train de me dire là c'est que
autant fil rouge à il peut être déçu de
jouer nakao premier tour autant la
caille planches peu de voir la gueule de
prendre si rogers premier tour aussi tu
vois n'est clairement te sentir comme
chez mme allard et enfin talent est là
enfin c'est le tyran très beau temps
verra bien mais après bon peut-être qui
- maxime jeu les pattes
hier j'ai regardé un peu les deux trois
dernières parties il a eu raison de
jouer pour s'entraîner moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que demain maxime milot
mêmes droits que meilleur tu vois si la
deux barres de connexion j'ai envie de
te dire c'est le penalty c'est maxime un
disque avec deux barres de connexion là
mon avis tu peux pas faire grand chose
il a un bundle à l'avouer moi ça me fait
un peu peur le truc de bundas à ckoi
c'est un pub tu joues en 4g ouais je
l'engagé ouais tu peux prendre un casier
il faut qu'en 2004 j'ai fini avec son
téléphone
ouais donc ça va aller il fait toujours
ce même chez moi le jour il voulait pas
mettre le wifi n'est qu'un jeu ça marche
aussi bien c'est mieux 4 général et ça
veut dire il sait qui c'est pas vrai
mais c'est qui qui va prendre du coup
bortnik parce que porte ni que c'est à
mon avis tu vois si importe nick aronian
pour moi important est d'être hyper
intéressant beaurinois demain ça va être
sympa pichai semaine dernière on avait
été un précieux qui perd un peu sonné
par un gagnant comme on s'attendait pas
le voir à ce niveau on l'avait enterré
direct et il l'avait fait des trucs
moins à greccio pays par peur série hbo
reporter grille tout qu en ingrid
chioukh fait pour moi partie qui les en
a quatre enfants boers 55 bortnik 1 si
je joue comme aujourd'hui
et à mon avis dans ta la partie de
tableau de la caf irujo ça va jouer le
vainqueur d'à rogne ancaria keane
qui est un cahier un truc fantastique
greccio va se préparer comme porto
l'accession parce qu'il peut ne pas
passer l'ouverture ils jouent collectif
et l'aap leader il va sarkar touché dans
le dos sauf que get you jo demain
asham pierre muller a préparé à ça c'est
très bon et usé bizarre non connaissant
un peu gris tchouk c'est possible que
pour lui le truc de bullet soit plus
important que kraft cham qui a manqué
oui non il a gagné à damas par tiers
chaque tiers mon kiné est revenu il a
besoin donc mais il affirmé j'ai raté
j'ai raté un épisode est basse
approchons de la fin du coup il y
revenir mais non il a deux ennemis sur 5
ha oui la paix - marshall personne mais
il n'est pas encore en bois je na waie
messei les bizarreries tchouk genre je
me rappelle quand je discute avec la de
gym et le spi de chasse par exemple pour
pour qui tout qu'est ce que ça vaut pour
lui c'était quasiment plus fins même pas
quasiment c'était un vrai titre et du
cool et on m'a fermé donc la finale sera
dimanche malheureusement le magistrat en
islande donc je pourrais pas commenter
ce que je voyage dimanche et mes parents
tu seras là boyer poste c'est la même
heure dimanche à nantes 19 heures donc
ça sera deux nuits finale au final ben
je sais pas encore écoute ou alors ce
sera une finale plus longue
peut-être mais probablement aller c'est
pas enfin personne tu vois j'étais à
larache on m'a fait déjà eu des
changements de dernière minute voilà le
nouveau système qu'ils ont testé va
peut-être pour d'autres c'est un marché
pour nous ça faisait la gate a eu dès
que j'ai fermé twitch pourra voir le
classement en même temps c'est on est
reparti et c'est mieux serait que la
méme mt contre angers en pratique pour
le classement quand il m'a donné cette
grande point doc la presse est beaucoup
mieux c'est un peu lent mais c'est quand
même assez rapide et on s'arrête on peut
le regarder tout le temps c'est beaucoup
mieux
obama que sur ce banc vous on va on va
souhaiter à tout le monde
l'avant centre montgré spong de manger
des coeurs
qu'on soit plus nombreux demain après
demain sera très nombreux c'est sûr
demain ça en vrai savon et de l'eau
moi j'ai un match important j'ai
marseille bordeaux 1 42 ans
c'est un truc qui m'a de bonnes soirées
qui m'attendent
quarante deux ans de quoi que bordeaux
gagne plus contre marseille ah non on
inverse que marseille a pas gagné à
bordeaux que marseille gagne à bordeaux
sané bordeaux
comment te dire c'est le seul match qui
nous attend l'année du comment joue mal
après bon vu une équipe c'est possible
et jusqu'à mallet bonsoir tout le monde
et pas demain merci à demain mathieu
tient pas devant tout le monde